про соцмережі і слух сьогодні поговоримо
От така служанка пані безугла вона на
вихідних Не було чим зайнятися замість
того щоб книжку якусь почитати Я не знаю
там зробити щось корисне не знаю Да вона
бавилася тим що проводила опитування в
Фейсбуці в соцмережах то вона там
проводила опитування Чи згодні всі що
всі депутати мають піти дружно на фронт
то чи потрібно всіх депутатів убити ну
власне неадекватні а на опитування але я
не бачу за ними Тільки дурості цієї пані
безуглої очевидно що це сценарій дуже
добре спланованой банковою Сьогодні вона
ну написала Там черговий пост що із
серії дроту європейської солідарності
треба відправити всіх Там під Іловайськ
і подивимося що буде можливо мінськ-3
цей пост вискочив Саме в той момент коли
європейська Солідарність оплакувала
нашого побратима який загинув під
вугледаром 25рі лідер нашої організації
європейської Солідарності в шості от над
цим от сміється пані безугла і запитує
та А що там роту послати європейської
солідарності на фронт чи ні я цей пост
прочитала в ту хвилину коли ми оплакуємо
наших партійців і ви як голова партії
слуга народу Як ви ставитеся до такого
розколу суспільства який На жаль а
демонструють ваші партійці члени вашої
фракції зокрема Мар'яна безугла І як це
вклядається інклюзивне відновлення на
національному рівні де мають бути точно
залучені представники всіх політичних
сил ми маємо 70 загиблих 70 загиблих і
2500 воюючих Я думаю що цьому треба
публічно поставити крапку насправді
європейська Солідарність більше 25ся
наших партійців воюють на фронті сотні з
них отримали поранення в тому числі і
важкі На жаль 70 наших колег загинули і
знаєте от наш офіс нагадує і
меморіальну дошку там стоять фотографії
в чорних рамочках дуже близьких дорогих
нам людей молодих прекрасних які мали би
будувати розбудовувати Україну пані
Ірино я знаходжусь тут на конференції не
читала соціальні мережі хто дещо там
написав
АА і перепалки переписки між Мар'яною і
Можливо там з кимось з вашої політичної
сили безмежна вдячні На завершення хочу
сказати безмежна вдячність нашим воїнам
які захищають і дають можливість нам тут
всім знаходитись в тилу нормально
працювати
а бачити життя ми правильно ви сказали
пані Ганно про цю програму вдячності Ми
повинні про неї постійно пам'ятати На
жаль ми не почули відповіді пані Шуляк
так само як і відповіді на інші
запитання які на цій конференції їй
задавали і взагалі слуги щодня доз
дозволяють собі ображати військових і я
нагадаю що ще один слуга там Який зараз
депутат облради Київської образив нашого
загиблого воїна Олега барну і ну це
ненормально і Мене лякає мовчання
керівництва парламенту от знаєте
стефанчук там карнієнка вся президія
Вони дуже люблять коментувати опозицію
що не скаже європейська Солідарність у
них завжди там на це є коментар якийсь
там такий Да упражняються в своїх
комплексах а тут марана безугла просто
чотири дні пише Ну якусь єрість про
парламент всіх вбити повісити посадити
зарізати мовчання повне І не таке
відчуття що вони навіть теж хайпують і
тащаться від того що увага прикута до
такох от Ну відвертого хайпу а не до
серйозних речей і звичайно пам'ять про
наших побратимів не дозволить ніколи нам
дати кому-небудь їх ображати і
принижувати і тому я уже зареєструвала
Постанову Верховної Ради України будемо
вимагати її розглянути в залі про
відкликання безуглої з члена комітета
нацбезпеки оборони Ну і взагалі знаєте Я
думаю що безугла робить таку дуже
корисну для офісу президента роботу
збираючи на себе негатив і демонструючи
ну таку просто невміняємость якусь
парламенту і це ж інших там не показують
в Марафоні І от така картинка в людей що
на начебто депутати всі такі в державі
демократичній європейській якою має бути
Україна повинні залишатися сильний
парламент до цього парламенту має бути
повага і базується ця повага не просто ж
на назві А на поведінці самих депутатів
яку На жаль от слуги ми бачимо
дискредитують взагалі цікаво от я бачу в
коментарях там в моїх соцмережах пишуть
Багато наших читачів слухачів що можливо
потрібно вносити і змін до законодавства
до закону про народно статус народного
депутата не тільки про те що подаючи
документи до
ЦВК кандидати там мають надати
біографію атестати там декларацію а і
довідку про психічне здоров'я Мені
здається що деякі нові обличчя настільки
дискредитували от
своїм безвідповідальністю статус
народного депутата що можливо такі зміни
і потрібно внести в законода
взагалі я хочу сказати що от сьогодні в
Києві відбулося кілька заходів які були
присвячені таким дискусіям про перші
повоєнні вибори те що активізувалися ці
дискусії означають що на банковій
розглядають можливість все-таки
проведення виборів десь весною але для
нас дуже важливо щоби ці вибори були в
проводилися за стандартами ОБСЄ щоби
вони проводилися в безпечному середовищі
сьогодні про це не може бути і мови коли
щодня українські міста і села
обстрілюють Ну і звичайно щоб вони були
демократичними з цим теж велика проблема
і біда І цікаво от що на цих круглих
столах я я про це окремий хочу до речі
блог записати Якщо вам цікаво то
поставте там плюсик в коментарях
напишіть Що пані Ірино давайте
обов'язково нам цікаво такий окремий
блог про вибори там Що там на цих
конференціях обговорювали що говорили
слуги вони визнають що найбільш таким
проблемним буде участь е в виборчому в
дні голосування військових і
переселенців як внутрішніх так і тих хто
за кордоном при цьому говорять про
військових Тільки от Ми маємо
забезпечити їх можливість там
голосування щоби там з фронту їх довести
до найближчих виборчих дільниць Я в
своєму виступі на іншому акцентувала
увагу Вибачте до ЗСУ сьогодні найбільша
Довіра е суспільства очевидно що
військові мають не тільки в бюлетенях
галочку поставити за нових нових облич а
самі бути присутні ми в парламенті в
місцевих органах влади і звичайно ми
тоді повинні забезпечити не тільки
участь депута військових Вибачте в
голосуванні а в самому виборчому процесі
А як це зробити під час війни як вони
будуть агітувати за себе покладуть зброю
і підуть брати участь в агітації
Звичайно що це все дуже важкі питання І
тому ми стоймо на позиції що вибори
мають відбуватися після завершення
воєнного стану і коли безугла в своїх
безумних постах згадує Мінськ Я хочу або
Іловайськ то я і хочу на останок
нагадати що завдяки важким мінським
угодам Нам вдалося утримати Україну
в звільнити 2/3ни окупованого Росією
Донбасу утримати Україну від
повномасштабного вторгнення Російської
Федерації в 14му році І власне на 200%
своя для Зеленського генпрокурорка в
іктова в спеціальній доповіді заявила що
до трагедії Іловайська до вбивства там
українських військовослужбовців були
причетні військові російської регулярної
армії тобто винна в іловайській трагедії
як і в дебальцівській як і в трагедії
Даб очевидно що Російська Федерація але
Мінські угоди дали можливість звільнити
і авдіївку і Маріуполь і Попасну і
Северодонецк і Лисичанськ всі ті міста
які сьогодні захоплені знищені руснею
просто і не безугля розповідати щось в
умовах сотень тисяч загиблих українців
про роти взводи і батальйони і і бригади
питань до неї і до них дуже багато і
тільки те що зараз триває повномасштабне
вторгнення І що так багато трагедій
щодня і наші військові щодня своїми
життями просто боронять Україну від цієї
навали Ми тримаємо єдність В окопах там
де солдати наші там точно немає політики
немає партій не запитують хто там за
кого голосував тому що там всі за
Україну Я би дуже радила слугам там
подумати над тим що несуть яку у поргу
їх деякі депутати з комітету нацбезпеки
і оборони І дійсно пані безуглу звідти
якось вилучити а ми будемо на цьому
наполягати тому що безпека України вона
в об'єднанні не навколо персонажів
якихось у владі а навколо збройних сил
України безпека України в нашій єдності
безпека України в наших сильних
інститутах в тому числі і в парламенті
де мають працювати Точно ну адекватні
відповідальні і дорослі люди нові деякі
обличчя відверто лякають
погоджуєтеся пишіть в коментарях
лайкайте і слава збройним силам України
а пам'ять наших загиблих героїв ми
нікому не дамо образити